ma la vedo fine di far estinto ma allora
mi ha notificato in tanti non è vero ho
visto il video di quei due sul server
che esiste questo gioco chiamato alt f4
che già il nome è una garanzia
ma la cosa incredibilmente carina e che
è un gioco di ostacoli sostanzialmente
poi la cat mario fatto meglio
c'è uno che l'mi6 spaccato logo preso un
pulcino melo sono messo nella sacca e
adesso una gallina e nel caricamento
allora c'è chi ha battuto il record del
mondo visto gioco suonata controllare in
tre minuti e qualcosa qui c'è poi non so
i tasti quindi chi se ne frega burqa
troy non ho capito ho lanciato un gap ma
cosa dal re ma povero non ho capito cosa
si può fare questa gallina ma
chissenefrega vagoni è l'inizio
ce la siamo fatta loro ok ok no male
ragano male
beh per adesso non è niente di cody di
trascendentale vogliamo dire ma ci sono
ricette porca vacca spetta a posto
la cosa ragazzi che mi dà più fastidio
visto gioco fino adesso la musica che
potrei anche credo dice ma lei lo skip
anche strano skip bello grosso quello si
può fare sono poi sta roba aspettarli no
porca [ __ ] preso cam
mica è stata è molto lento il fatto che
tu debba morire cadendo proprio 18 così
poi sei una piuma quindi cadice
mentitore a cadere andiamo avanti non
c'è modo di correre c'è questa massima
velocità
c'e la prima perso la prima persona è
orribile
allora superato il primo punto all 8
quando donna c è già un casino qui c'è
figurati sono vivo sonnino mi sono
buttato per terra
be nice ma sto sanguinando da più per da
più punti ma fa niente
cos'è sta roba c'è un pallone posso
colpirlo con un pollo no va bene stai
gioco o dio e che cos'è la sponde ca o
dio volendo ragazzi incredibile ho fatto
la roma ho fatto una provata pazzesca
però poi sono morto peccato e ci avevo
creduto ma e mi devi fare iniziare da
capo tutte le volte ce ne se c'è un
check point spero che se gioco andrà
anche un po check point sarà un disastro
ma parliamoci chiaro ragazzi cioè senza
cioè che poi che lo posso fare una sega
il suo gioco
ok bella no madonna ci vuole un tempismo
pazzesco per osservare su sta roba
lasciare i meriti corpi giù va bene
allora piano fino qua è tutto a posto ed
è una cagata estrae ha poi l'acqua
inizia un po a essere problematico
aspetta un attimo che capiscono che si
esca picchiarmi dietro l'albero va bene
perfetta fin qua
fin qua save
ma l'ho colpito perché c'è scritto sei
quelli in seno ai ragazzi ci sono i
check point semplicemente non so come
prenderli vabbè ok non è vero mai nella
vita posso sono svenuto apposta perché
se non mi prende qualcosa va bene allora
siamo andati lontano non so ma porc si
muovono sti affari anche questo qua non
è vero no ragazzi miei film mi rifiuto
amici non si ok va bene a posto tutto ok
allora dove devo andare esattamente
cielo passare sulle spine no ma è la
malattia aspettavo che è a posto
non so come ok ce l'ho fatta pazzesco
datemi il salvataggio vivrei vi supplico
potevo fare qua quando passati sopra e
sotto non si capisce 18
non si capisce però scendere al massimo
questa ok rino al di sotto di sotto
perfetto allora quello credo che
rimbalzi non ne sono sicurissimo vediamo
non rimbalza mi sono fidato della fisica
che non esiste giocato troppo a bugs
bunny quando ero piccola rimbalzano gli
affari sono c'è da prendere come
salvataggio c'è veramente assurda sta
roba
ok non è vero o mio dio ce l'ho fatta
non ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatto apposta
stavolta l'ha fatta veramente veloce
come
cosa posso risotto bene questa è
veramente facile questo ecco allora qual
è sufficiente saltare quindi mi sento
salto normal va bene va bene
proprio lui ecco al casinò madonna ma no
vabbè ragazzi
progaming però non so come non so che ho
fatto mi sono fatta bene a posto barili
ole ole alcune fatto non c'è un altro
salvataggio a qualche parte che un ora
che gioco ma quando andare molto prima
scommetti madonna che giocata ho fatto
la possa andare a letto posso skippare
qua scusami passion hanno messo un muro
invisibile non mi fido a scappare
non mi fido prova a scappare neanche per
sbaglio lo schifo io skipper ehi ma non
schifo non fa una piega
aro key molto bene a posto molto bene
ragazzi e per il mio solito standard
ma io che cazzo farlo adesso se io
riparto da lino storicamente dove
funzione che poi non lo so e lo
scopriamo subito allora 33esimo
cavaliere
fammi sognare costava musica poi non
scriviamo niente che tanto il tempo non
ce ne frega nulla
ok appena moio e morirò questa musica
verrà lanciata dalla finestra
[Musica]
mamma mia che giocatori fermi falsi tct
zitti zitti zitti
due ore per tornare qua due ore due ore
due ore per tornare qua perfetto
perfetto perfetto e adesso vai vai
veloce veloce le no non facente nel
proprio tra cazzata ma tu che culo sto
male sicure servizi se mi tuffo ci
arrivo no vabbè non lo faccio
l'ho detto già prima asta rosa ma non
l'ho voluto fare e non lo farò va bene e
fino qua come ho fatto a morire prima ma
chiedo non mi sono più questo potrebbe
essere un problema
aspetta aspetta
ok ok va bene allora fino qua ok ci sono
dei pesci ma tutto a posto dei pesci che
potrebbero buttarmi giù ma è tutto a
posto
per favore pesci state calmi anche come
un problema va bene ma donna che però
ragazzina per juan mai arrivato fino qua
bene capitana o questi sono pazzi non è
solo un fenomeno non solo presso pub e
nei panni di skill sui giochi così che
cazzo devo fare poi aiuto
e va beh mi sembra un po eccessivo
signori però lascia decidere a voi era
sfalsato di 2 in 2 sti stron
raga la casa gamberame non fate domande
per cortesia non le fate non le fa non
scrivete niente nei commenti
non voglio commento ok ok o calma calma
calma voci datemi un save per l'amore di
gesù bambino allora qua c'è un ponte di
una certa troppa tranquillità però
proviamoci
oh cazzo o santo di dio no hai preso
pazzini che mi dissocio mi fido
[Musica]
no